so it's going to be extremely important
that our AGI systems want the right
things that is they have the right kind
of goals or as people put it these days
that they are aligned with uh with human
goals because if they're
if they're even a little bit misaligned
then there's going to be the capacity
for things to go very badly wrong I know
there are some people who think that the
alignment is going to have to be so
precise that you know missed by just the
tiniest bit and we'll we'll destroy the
universe whereas others think it's uh
it's extremely robust uh it may be more
robust than that I'm not totally sure
about that but I'm certainly on the side
of people who think we have to take this
issue extremely seriously and there is
at least potential existential risks
here that if AGI is produced in an I'm
thinking way perhaps say in a military
or a financial context where there's a
AI arms race
um and you suddenly and we suddenly have
um greater than human AIS that can that
can achieve other free goals